oh
salut aujourd'hui nous sommes le 30
juillet et c'est la dernière vidéo du
mois de juillet mais aussi la dernière
vidéo de cet été pourquoi écoutez je
vais vous le dire tout de suite pour
deux raisons qu'il devrait vous
intéresser et en plus à la fin de la
vidéo je vais vous dire quelque chose
qui devrait encore plus vous intéresser
je fais clairement beaucoup trop de
gestes
la première raison c'est que souvenez
vous cet été je devais pas faire de
vidéos du tout pour préparer des gros
projets de la rentrée une sorte de
renouveau de la chaîne wii alors on a vu
dans l'introduction de 20 secondes
durant vingt vidéo ça on avait compris
et pour pas vous laisser sans rien
justement je vous avais préparé cette
surprise de faire une vidéo tous les
deux jours sur un format très court mais
en fait je crois que ça marche pas comme
idée parce que si je m'étais pas d'intro
qui expliquait alors tout le monde ne
croyez que la chaîne c'était devenu sa
forme et et l'intro au contraire une
partie d'entre vous en avez marre de la
voir et dire on l'a compris est assez
majoritairement vous trouviez les vidéos
pas assez complète fourmi qui était
justement la base de ce concept de faire
des vidéos d'une ou deux minutes
la deuxième raison est beaucoup plus
intéressante c'est que durant tout ce
mois de juillet j'ai beaucoup écrit et
penser à ce que l'on allait faire sur la
chaîne maintenant le truc qui va vous
plaire c'est qu'entre temps à revenir
des gros fondamentaux quand je mentalise
des gens quand je vous expliquer un tour
de mentalisme que vous pouvez refaire
quand je vous donne des astuces sur la
mémoire mais dans des formats encore
plus varié plus travailler et pour sa
plus prévu parce qu'ici depuis le 1er
janvier 2016
on pense à sa vidéo deux jours avant un
jour avant voir le matin donc c'est
toujours en plus tendues et parfois j'ai
des bonnes idées que j'ai pas le temps
de mettre en place un exemple très
simple qui va vous spoiler un peu mais
depuis depuis presque un an je veux
faire une vidéo d'hypnose sur la chaîne
connaissant bien et pratiquant l'hypnose
je veux pas faire n'importe quoi je vous
faire quelque chose d'assez variés et là
c'est précis aussi et bien si je prends
du temps en août je vais pouvoir la
réaliser elle sortir en septembre et
pour tous ses projets toutes ces idées
me faut un maximum de temps au mois
d'août afin de créer une sorte de dents
avance donc c'est parti pas de vidéo en
outre une reprise en septembre et alors
c'est là que ça devrait vous plaire j'ai
prévu un nouveau planning
alors attention l'annoncé très
solennelle
[Musique]
à partir du 1er septembre il y aura une
vidéo tous les mardis et tous les
vendredis à 15 heures sur la chaîne les
mardis et les vendredis à 15 et un
nouveau rendez-vous en plus ça ces bonus
chaque dernier mercredi du mois à 20h20
les vrais savent il y aura un live sur
la chaîne
voilà ça commence le 1er septembre donc
d'ici là évidemment y aura plus de
vidéos sur la chaîne mais on doit être
grosso modo à 450 vidéo si vous venez
d'arriver
vous pouvez regarder il ya plein de
choses qui ont été traitées si vous
faites partie des anciens vous pouvez
revoir des vidéos et quoi qu'il arrive
d'être actif sur un staff nacha twitter
facebook vous avez tous les liens dans
la description eux puissent ils ont
profité de l'été pour vous quittez un
peu je sais pas par exemple un livre qui
va vous donner toutes les bases sur le
mentalisme et dont le lien est la vidéo
présentation serait dans la description
par exemple mais j'ai tellement hâte
d'être en septembre pour vous faire voir
tout ce que je préparais pour la chaîne
en attendant passer un bon mois d'août
profiter du soleil
faites vous plaisir déconnecté et donc
rendez vous le 1er septembre ce sera
donc à vendredi ça sortira 15h charge
[Musique]